and there are managed with our
operational partnerships and benefits of
home security
connectivity operation final change Asia
[Music]
our nation's
[Music]
the situation if your K will be I
imagine high on the agenda looking for
ways to peacefully resolve the crisis
and leading to the funerals ation of the
Korean Peninsula let me also share that
we just had an informal briefing
the state councillor onsen sushi on the
situation in the Rockland states that I
found extremely encouraging I'm coming
myself directly from Bangladesh where I
was visiting
some of the refugee camps yesterday and
having meetings with the prime minister
of Bangladesh and I would say that I'm
very much encouraged by the possibility
that I believe it's real and concrete of
Myanmar and Bangladesh reach human
agreements on a bilateral Memorandum of
Understanding for the repatriation of
refugees that would constitute a first
important step for the implementation of
the Anan reports recommendation